skies Katy Spencer has details of new
figures just released on on the UK Katy
bring us up to date the UK figures have
just come out released by the Department
of Health and while their overall show
that there is a bigger increase than
we've seen in the last couple of days
what it does show though is that even
though there is that increase the
numbers of stabilizing so that is the
numbers of confirmed cases for the UK as
now stands at 129 thousand and 44 the
number of deaths for the UK has
increased by 828 deaths taking the total
now to seventeen thousand three hundred
and thirty-seven now compare that to
yesterday's increase of four hundred and
forty nine yesterday eight hundred and
twenty eight today it is a lot more but
we kind of to an extent we're expecting
this what you see at this time of the
week is the weekend effect there's been
delays in collating the data over the
weekend and while that might sound like
a lot more actually if you compare it to
some of the numbers that we were seeing
last week the week before actually it's
not as high as some of the figures that
we've seen and the other thing that that
does tell us as well as the number of
tests we know the government has said by
the end of this month they want to be
reaching a hundred thousand tests this
says that yesterday they managed just
slightly over 18,000 tests less than the
day before I think the day before it was
nineteen thousand three hundred today's
data shows 18,000 so a long way off that
100,000 targets what we can give you
actually as the the picture of the
nation's as well and how the individual
data has been collated within the region
as well should we take you through what
the picture is in England at the moment
as well so in England the data that
we've learned this afternoon shows that
seven hundred and seventy eight people
have confirmed to have died in hospital
after testing positive for kovat 19
while that might sound high it's
actually worth noting that that's lower
than saturday's totals for England the
largest number of deaths recorded in the
northwest of England that's a hundred
and seventy two they're more than London
London was only a hundred and thirty two
so it
perhaps as a sign that London has now
passed it speaking cases but that takes
the total number of confirmed hospital
deaths in England now to 15,000 607 so a
bigger eyes than we've seen in the last
couple of days but that could be down to
the weekend effect as we've just spoken
about as well but then it's still not as
high as we've seen when the data has
been it's worse we can show you now what
the situation was in Scotland as well
seventy more deaths in hospitals in
Scotland taken the total there to nine
hundred and eighty five we've seen 25
more Hospital deaths in Wales bringing
their total 609 and at this stage we're
still waiting for the update from
northern and I of Northern Ireland but
of yesterday a hundred and ninety four
people had died with the coronavirus in
hospitals there I think really the hope
was that perhaps because we'd see it had
a couple of days where the numbers had
been fairly low if the numbers had
continued to be low perhaps that would
have been a sign that we were now
officially past the peak but I think the
fact that these numbers are consistently
tending to plateau rather than go down
that it's a sign that we haven't quite
past the peak that's what I would read
from these and our number crunchers have
actually been looking at the data in a
bit more detail and they said that the
increase in deaths that we've seen today
that's around 5% on yesterday's numbers
that we were seeing worth noting as well
the ons data that we saw this morning
that actually showed this huge disparity
that we can see between the daily
numbers that we give out and actually
the ons numbers which give us the
figures for care homes and the community
as well at the ons figures that we saw
this morning for the week ending April
the 10th they showed a 41% disparity a
difference between the daily figures and
the ons figures so it's likely that
actually the numbers could be a lot
bigger than what we've seen today yeah
but I mean the ons figures are giving us
at least an indication of what is
happening in care homes and in the
community yes and what we're learning
from that actually is that it's
significantly much larger than the
situation that we find ourselves in with
these daily figures which are
exclusively just hospitalizations what
the OH&S figures include a care home
death community deaths and also any
death we're on the death certificate
there is a possibility and the kovat 19
is recording on the death disk
certificate as a possibility of course
of death so it does give us a lot more
information the ons numbers but they
take a lot longer to collate because
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of care homes that they have
to try to get the information from
rather than just from the individual
hospital trust which is why the daily
data gives us a the most up-to-date data
but it perhaps doesn't give us the most
precise picture of what exactly is
happening within communities okay Katy
thank you very much